[Musica]
Vi faccio una domanda utopica se il
canone di bellezza che ci impone la
società non esistesse
vorresti comunque cambiare quella parte
del vostro corpo che tanto odiate
Pensateci e mi piacerebbe sapere la
risposta dopo
non so quando non so chi però quando ero
bambina Qualcuno
ha impresso nel mio immaginario in
maniera indelebile che le donne per
piacere per essere chiamate donne per
essere considerate
all'altezza dovessero essere piccole
aggraziate praticamente tutto il
contrario di come ero io
la più alta della classe la più grassa
la più pelosa è questa parte è soltanto
dolorosa personalmente e la più
maldestra capace di cadere anche ferma
in piedi
sono cresciuta in uno stato di
inadeguatezza che mi ha portato ad
avviare ogni millimetro nel mio corpo e
anche della mia personalità in questo
momento della mia vita il fatto che io
odiassi addirittura anche la mia
personalità è la cosa che mi ferisce di
più
quando mi chiedevano cosa vuoi fare da
grande io rispondevo l'attrice ed era
vero ma in realtà se ci pensavo bene
Volevo rispondere la donna esile e
aggraziata è elegante
Vi giuro che provo veramente tanta
vergogna a rivelarvi questo segreto ma
ho bisogno di farvi capire l'importanza
che avesse il corpo nell'ambiente in cui
sono cresciuta io nasco a Bari ma vengo
trapiantata a Milano poco più di 4 anni
in un paesino apparentemente Perfetto
pleasantville se vogliamo fare un
riferimento cinematografico Mio padre
aveva scelto quel posto Perché l'aria
profumava di pini e immaginava me a
giocare in tutti quegli aree verdi alla
fine venivo da Bari tanto tanto cemento
purtroppo quel Giardino dell'Eden era
solo apparenza perché era proprio
l'apparenza L'unica cosa che contava
alle medie il solo desiderio che avevo
era quella di confondermi tra le mie
compagnette di classe e invece per colpa
della mia stazza L'unica cosa che
sembrava è che io sembrava la loro baby
sitter oltre all'altezza anche il mio
peso non mi ha mai aiutata io sono
sempre stata grassa e però crescendo
all'inizio degli anni 90 non mi sono
stati dati i giusti strumenti per vedere
il cibo come carburante per il mio corpo
bensì fin dall'asilo per me era una
ricompensa qualcosa che andava meritato
scusate
[Applauso]
il
la privazione di così tanti alimenti mi
portarono a diventare una ladra io ero
una ladra di cibo in casa mia
ci sono gli zeppe di storie che
potrebbero raccontarvi mia madre ad oggi
ci ridiamo su ma in realtà non ci
sarebbe troppo da ridere
Io sono sempre stata molto emotiva
veramente tanto ma non sono mai stata in
grado di capire e riconoscere quali
emozioni o stessi provando e quindi cosa
succedeva io Felice mangiavo di nascosto
ero triste andavo nel freezer e mangiavo
i Sofficini surgelati
se ero arrabbiata mangiavo tutto il cibo
che trovavo davanti Dolce e Salato fino
a sentirmi male
questo
sentirmi diversa il non riuscire a
capire le mie emozioni a riconoscerle e
accettarle
vedere i miei compagni i miei coetanei
così diversi da me mi portarono a
sviluppare un disturbo del comportamento
alimentare il bingiting questa parolona
inglese adesso dopo la pandemia è
sdoganata socialmente accettata ma io ne
soffrivo all'inizio degli anni 2000 e a
quel tempo eri solo una piega
alle superiori durante l'adolescenza
incontro la bulimia ormai ero abituata
alle centinaia di diete ancora stato
sottoposta Io penso che la prima dieta
fatta alle elementari sono già all'asilo
passo lunghi periodi a fisarmonica
con molto molto sport privazione di cibo
e inevitabile abbuffate che finivano
sempre con due dita in gola
Il sentirmi non capita Perché i miei
genitori non mi capivano i miei
insegnanti non mi capivano le mie
coetanei e non mi capivano mi porta a
passare tanto tempo da sola con la mia
immaginazione e questo mi fa sviluppare
una moltitudine di passioni come la
musica il disegno e la fotografia
fotografia cardine di tutto tutta la mia
crescita io fotografavo le mie amiche
Oppure delle coetanee che
rappresentavano tutto quello che voleva
essere io magre belle ed erano belle ai
miei occhi perché erano magre e molto
aggraziato e molto eleganti io ero la
ragazza grassa del gruppo e per puro
spirito di sopravvivenza ho dovuto
sviluppare uno spiccato senso
dell'umorismo per integrarmi Infatti ero
la più simpatica quella che faceva
ridere tutti e soprattutto la più brava
a prendermi in giro da sola così da
evitare che lo facessero gli altri
Ovviamente con scarsissimi risultati
perché commenti da parte di persone che
conoscevo e soprattutto da sconosciuti
come ad esempio davanti una discoteca Un
sabato sera non mancavano mai Infatti
non ho mai permesso che nessuna persona
a me cara venisse presa di Mira come
invece succedeva a me
oltre alla simpatia sviluppo Purtroppo
anche tanta aggressività Ma come darmi
torto E dava fastidio che tutti mi
conoscevano come la simpaticona che si
arrabbiava troppo facilmente io non mi
arrabbiavo troppo facilmente io avevo
delle ragioni e infatti questo spiccato
senso di giustizia mi porta ad
avvicinarmi sempre di più a delle
tematiche sociali che mi facevano
sentire viva come ad esempio le
battaglie della comunità lgbt qui a Plus
e poi ho capito perché mi sentivo così
legata alle loro battaglie e razzismo e
le discriminazioni che subivano le donne
ovvero che subivo io portandomi a
parlare sempre più apertamente le mie
ideali Ok adesso voi dovete immaginarvi
me 15 anni esattamente alta come adesso
per 115 kg con un tono di voce molto
alto e un senso di giustizia
particolarmente
sviluppato io ero letteralmente una
spina nel fianco voi non avete idea di
quante volte mi sia stato chiesto
puoi abbassare la voce
quante volte mi sia stato detto sarà
oggi non parlare delle tue idee come se
potessi far scatenare una guerra
mondiale con quello che pensavo e quello
che credevo e quante volte mi sia stato
fatto notare che se io non volessi
cambiare il mio corpo Allora avrei
dovuto nasconderlo con dei vestiti neri
e coprenti
a vent'anni ero veramente soffocata
dalla mia realtà e quindi prendo una
decisione forse la più intelligente
della mia vita
partire per Londra Io per la prima volta
mi sento Non mi sento un pesce fuor
d'acqua cioè io mi sono resa conto che
nella folla mentre camminavo non ero più
la più alta loro più la più grassa non
ero più la più rumorosa più la più
maldestra io ero normale Cioè voi vi
immaginate che sogno può essere che Che
sollievo può essere essere essere
normale
confonderti nessuno ti nota perché sei
uguale a tutti gli altri o felicissima
di questa cosa
sul posto di lavoro vengo trattata con
rispetto pesavo 130 kg e nonostante
questo in soli otto mesi ricevo due
promozioni io lavoravo a contatto con il
pubblico e mai una volta il mio corpo
che in Italia non sarebbe stato reputato
di bella presenza neanche per sbaglio mi
ha limitata
purtroppo
i pensieri intrusivi disturbi alimentari
non mi abbandonano e mi portano a
prendere una decisione
molto dolorosa ma necessaria tornare in
Italia
incomincio quindi un percorso
psicoterapeutico che oltre a fare conto
il conto con 26 anni e di demoni
interiori mi accompagna e sostiene
durante il delicatissimo intervento di
bypass gastrico a cui decide di
sottopormi mi sottopongo a questo
intervento e se dicessi che l'ho fatto
solo per la mia salute sarai falsa io
non mi riconoscevo nel mio corpo
soffrivo di dismorfofobia ogni volta che
vedevo la mia immagine
riflessa in un vetro
avevo un trauma perché io non sapevo chi
fosse quella persona adesso facciamo un
salto temporale siamo ad agosto 2021 io
ho perso 63 kg ho perso letteralmente un
essere umano
Finalmente sono magra
E perché sono così triste Cioè per tutta
la vita mi hanno fatto credere che se il
mio corpo fosse rientrato in uno
standard di bellezza se fossi stata
magra se fossi stata come le altre
allora sarei stata felice appagata è
perché vorrei solo sparire allora
cominciò a provare anche una
irresistibile piacere nel sentirmi dire
Mamma mia Sara però sei dimagrita troppo
che si vedono le ossa Stai mangiando
Cosa hai mangiato oggi non ci credo
Sapete dove mi ha portato questo
refrenabile piacere
in un centro per disturbi alimentari
davanti a uno psichiatra che per la
prima volta nella mia vita mi prescrive
degli psicofarmaci
Io fra qualche mese farò 30 anni e sono
stanca io sono stanca di combattere
contro me stessa sono stanca di pensare
che il mondo l'unica cosa che ti porti
di me sia la circonferenza delle mie
cosce mi rifiuto di pensare che sia così
E dopo tanti anni di terapia e ricerca
interiore posso dire a tutti voi e a
tutte le bambine come come lo ero io che
essere magri non vi renderà felici
cercare di omologare il vostro corpo in
uno standard sociale rincorrere la
perfezione cercare di cambiare tutte le
parti del vostro corpo che non vi
piacciono non vi farà stare meglio il
nostro corpo è la nostra casa e va
trattato con cura non per la pressione
sociale che sentiamo ma perché è l'unico
mezzo che abbiamo per vivere al meglio
questa vita
personalmente non voglio più farmi
piccola Non voglio occupare poco spazio
non voglio abbassare il tono della mia
voce e soprattutto non voglio smettere
di credere nei miei ideali perché io
come tutti voi meritiamo di esistere e
il mio corpo merita di esistere
[Applauso]
[Musica]